henri de toulouse lautrec avant gardiste
de l'art pictural du 19e siècle mais
surtout un amoureux des femmes de
montmartre du moulin rouge et des
bordels un choix que n'approuvera pas
toujours son père aristocrate comme le
rappelle une petite cuisine était déçu
par affi s'affirme et il aurait compris
que faire de la peinture se consacre aux
chevaux traits comme il l'a fait pendant
sa jeunesse
évidemment il ne pourrait pas du tout la
vie d'artiste en 1882 toulouse lautrec
s'installe à montmartre il est fasciné
par les femmes du peuple
il pense sans cesse ses modèles favoris
de carmen vue d'un achat noël l'artiste
passe tout son temps dans les maisons
closes et finit par peindre le quotidien
de ces femmes
claude roger marx son biographe
le rac août c'était avant toi un art
danse sensuelle un gourmand gourmande de
devis sous toutes les ce qu'il a cherché
d'ailleurs dans dans les maisons closes
c'est un contact un contact d'artistes
qui qui qui veut toucher autrement que
de que de l'oeil presse que c'était
d'aider des mains et de solutions désir
l'être féminin qui l'adoré compte il
côtoie aussi le montmartre de la nuit
amélie perret alors débutante dans la
troupe du moulin rouge sont bien ils
étaient là au moulin allouche presque
tous les soirs quand dans chez nous
regarder fixement
il immortalise plusieurs danseuses de
cabaret devenus des stars jeanne avril
yvette guilbert loïe fuller michel
georges michel critique littéraire de
l'époque impressionné par l'artiste nous
raconte une séance de pause avec la
célèbre chanteuse et actrice marcel
länder que cette dernière lui avait
confié quand elle posait votre et lui
demander de chanter un couplet de
chilpéric d'hervé quel jeu il joue et
aux variétés
mais ce couplet lautrec lui faisait
répéter chanter une fois 5 x 10 x 50 x
également dit mais monsieur lautrec
vous ne voulez pas que je chante
d'autres couples ramène ça me gênerait
alors pourquoi me faites vous chantez à
je vais vous dire ma demoiselle sait que
la peau de votre dos zizi à la lumière
jusque cherchait il meurt à 37 ans
alcoolique et attend de la syphilis
artiste prolifique il aura réalisé pas
moins de 730 cette peinture 275
aquarelles et 369 affiche qui saisiront
toute l'émotion de l'instant
[Musique]